I you know guys this is Reuben report
i'm still dave rubin i'm very excited
this week because we've all comedian
comedy panel felicia Michaels who you
good people know and paul provenza first
timer on Ruben part Paul what level of
nerves are you at right now first time
Felicia is a veteran it's always
difficult when you losing your virginity
all right well we're we're gonna Lube it
up and get right into it so here we go
new restaurant specializes in footlong
wieners watch out world the male
equivalent of hooters is ready for
business aptly named tallywhacker the
dining establishment is a farce stopped
by half-naked men serving phallic shaped
foods such as hot dogs although the
restaurant is located in a predominantly
gay neighborhood Deborah woman have
already voiced their enthusiasm for the
idea on the company's Facebook page I
haven't been here but I think this is an
amazing idea women enjoy looking at
scenic views too tallywhacker is
expected to open in dallas just in time
for Mother's Day it seems pretty clear
to me that this is going to be all gay
guys I don't sense women really going
you're a woman Felicia will women be
attending this place women will be
attending yes yes I would go I want to
go yeah I happy a lot of bachelorette
parties going her huh yeah I want to
know what their hair net policy is
though ah God is a good question across
the chest yes so you would go Paul do
you think there's any chance something
like this can actually work of course
what uh do the stupidest things in the
world work of course the advances of
work yeah this will probably go great
who knows it'll work for a wild moon
work I don't know look restaurants are
tough anyway regardless of what's
hanging out of people's shirts or pants
yeah who knows the restaurant business
it could go bad for a lot of reasons but
um you know I think it's hilarious
actually I think it's really funny um
Hooters do you go to hooters I you know
I go to hooters yeah when it's the only
thing open and I'm walking this I don't
know if you ever worked Stanford and
Sons in Kansas City no but it's actually
in hooters plaza ah which is I believe
the cultural center of Kansas City and
yeah you just go around the corner and
have some great chicken wings and all
right so it'll just typically go to
hooters for the hooting so it's not
necessarily for the moves I don't I
don't care who's serving me if the food
is good and the service is good I don't
give a [ __ ] get me chimps yeah how do
girls feel about who have you been to
hooters I have been to hooters I don't
have a problem with it personally but I
read somewhere that they're gonna have a
hooters airlines I think they were at
one time and I don't know that it
actually happy it had something two my
nice to meet right in your face no I got
you got it I would go to that restaurant
but my only complaint is tali whackers
white alley one morning is that what is
that it's supposed to mean like a penis
and some kind of subtle like language is
that sleigh is it I think there's some
subtle is there something Stalley wed
when you get down to it when you get
down to the logistics of who will allow
you to advertise his but you can't go on
with like schlong meister like chick
sickle okay I like that right screw
again whatever you is it food or
atmosphere well atmosphere atmosphere
atmosphere yeah corn dogs yeah well
you're gonna get plenty of order I think
it is if it is in the gay neighborhoods
and it is going to focus on the game
market they're gonna have to turn the
lights down really low yeah and maybe
put holes in the tables and the side
walls and things and then then you got
an interesting franchise uh would you
guys go to tally whackers do you like
the footlong hot dog let us know the
comments right down below if you don't
eat your meat you can't have your edible
passwords PayPal's head of global
development Jonathan LeBlanc has
released a presentation on the future of
password and it has nothing to do with a
combination of numbers and special
characters instead LeBlanc wants to put
a chip into your brain or embedded
device in your belly that's powered by
your own stomach acid the so-called
natural body identification would
replace numerical pass code instead
tagging privileged users with their
biometric code AK a heartbeat glucose
levels and other specifics
in our own bodies right so you guys know
that i love these stories about future
stuff in technology and how it's
affecting our brains and our bodies
we're just gonna become robots right
like you a lot of stories on robot here
but are we just weird swallowing pills
look up possibly go wrong with that has
anybody ever seen 2001 yeah what could
possibly go wrong with this yeah Alexis
all wrong yes we amazed well my password
is gonna be Kafka yeah or or well like
just or well I'm just gonna swallow or
well and let it go through yeah what do
you think about this passwords how do
you manage your passwords right well I'm
running out of us like security
questions number one like I'm running
I'm like now making [ __ ] up yeah totally
running out but I saw you swallow the
pill does the password natural password
ID in it I think what would be worse
than forgetting your password is pooping
out your password what I mean like how
does that even work does it say
something about our society like we love
your password is diarrhea what does it
say about us that we love pills so much
every commercial right is for a pill and
then there's an hour of what pillow that
we would want to go this way if they
could if they could they'd just sneak up
behind you and lights and on the subway
I just engine never you tell you about
and that's coming to this is this is
just gonna get ugly yeah so we're gonna
do this I wouldn't if you're running out
of security question I don't think I
would do that but I also read that now
they are having tattoos that can do the
same thing with the password so that
would be the only reason to ever get a
tribal tattoo right I got the reason
finally really well they're just gonna
hack your arm off right right right
would be like Minority Report you know
and everything goes through your eye and
then one day they'll just come around
and rip your eye out or a hooker just
get a sort of barcode tattoo you gotta
just scan and he just goes right off you
are coded yeah I do what exactly yeah um
is cyber war
scarier in real war like to me this all
leads us every time we do a robot story
if you're sure to be this always lead to
Tuesday always was topic o is it's
always disturbing always leads to I
don't know what that says about me a lot
of pot inside i means I don't know well
like it always leads to Terminator and
Skynet and well I don't know you know
there's a dick it's just it's just more
opportunity for control and and I am so
suspicious yes of that that that I want
no part of it but you know I can't get
around but you can't fight it what are
you gonna do everyone's gonna be
swallowing aerials and you're gonna have
no pass all my passwords are now snow d
there was no my password every day oh
yeah yeah anyway what do you think
swallowed passwords crazy would you do
it let us know in the comments right
down below you're not gonna believe this
but the White House press corps has
actually decided to start working in
order to increase day-to-day
transparency the White House
Correspondents Association is seeking
more meaningful and consistent access to
the president LA Times reporter and
president of the whca Christi Parsons
claimed it's time for White House
Correspondents to band together in
response to a number of issues including
a lack of opportunities to question the
president and the White House appearing
to bypass the press corps through social
media the whca is urging the President
to hold a full press conference with a
rotating pool of official reporters at
least once a month the Association also
wants to hold free themes on record
instead of on background forcing
administration participants be
recognized by name instead of as senior
officials their angle is quote a
statement we all support a shared vision
of an open and transparent way
not just for this White House Minh but
four administration's to come all right
I'm pretty sure I can speak for the
whole panel here when I say that
generally the media does a pretty shitty
job am I can I speak for you guys when I
say then generally when it when it comes
to holding our politicians and our
presidents to account they do a pretty
shitty job okay there yes hey we're
angry are you a boy it's kind of a
give-and-take system there you know the
White House on the press they they kind
of have this kind of mutual jack off on
right now which which is important to
understand yeah except we're the ones
getting screwed yeah there's there's no
there's no there's a lot of cozying up
that goes on there and you know in terms
of access that's often used as a
currency where you know you print that
story you'll never get access to this a
whole other world that you want to cover
blah blah blah so it's always been
corrupt but this this new transparency
yeah garbage it's very so that's that is
a purely garbage because of course for
six years this administration has been
saying it's the most transparent
administration ever meanwhile Snowden
and James clapper the head of CIA lied
to Congress he's fine Snowden's out of
the country and there's a zillion other
examples of that and and all the
backroom dealing and the fact that you
know the fact that bills are passed in
Congress and in the Senate where even
the representatives themselves don't
even get a chance to have access to the
material in the bill right this is crazy
here's the deal you know in the UK they
have something that's fantastic and I
would love to see it here because here
we're not as polite as they are in the
UK right over the UK they do this thing
called prime minister question time and
and yeah they get really really really
agitated huh and I would love to see
that happen here in America where they
don't know from agitation they don't
know from from going crazy on somebody
yeah I would love to see that here and
understand why we don't have yes I used
to do a bit about that actually cuz they
generally yell at each other they yell
at each other and yet what we do here is
we go the distinguished gentleman from
Tennessee and it's like you know that
guys [ __ ] idiot and it's like we do
this game but is this to me this is sort
of the worst of what I've sort of not
like
about this administration that they like
openness that was what the idea would ya
him and we'll say we wanted openness but
to me there's nothing better about this
administration in that regard than there
was before and if anything we prosecute
more reporters than ever before I mean
well you know I totally get what you
guys are saying but here I kind of feel
like you guys are right but no one wants
to know the complete truth number one
number true yeah two is you all said
number true number two number two is it
sounds like their feelings are hurt like
little baby [ __ ] they are so sad that
the president just isn't that into them
yeah I'm being like you know they what
are they what kind of demands you know
don't want right yeah it's not fair to
go after the press for trying to do you
know what we're decrying that they're
not doing right now I mean yeah they
should be whiny little [ __ ] one would
be completely transparent when now
they're saying there's an 11 examples of
Brian Williams you know exaggerating the
truth I mean you know which clears no
matter by the Brian Williams who of
course was the only person fired because
of a lie of the Iraq war that's a whole
yeah yeah so in in a weird way while I'm
being critical of Obama here he's just
doing what anyone else would do right if
you were the president what have you do
everything in your power never to sit
down and answer questions that you
didn't watch it yeah that's all he's
doing right I don't know it is there's
something very wrong with the entire
system from top to bottom and that's why
nobody can speak openly about it that's
why transparency is such a threat to the
entire institution so yeah I mean but
you know look I come from the point of
view that there is no president they can
make a difference this is his system is
so much larger than one person or one
administration that it doesn't matter
and I think that you know I think that
he does a lot of glad-handing he has to
he's the president it's politics and
it's all glad-handing yeah you want to
you want to count wise let's go through
every president ever yeah and you see
who has the fewest so do you kind of by
the the bill Hicks theory you know he
used to do that thing about the day you
become president they show you a file
and it shows well you know what shows
okay okay assassins you know we're like
those days
Woodrow Wilson on I've been warned about
it and in in an ascending graph chart
we've been warned about you know the
development of a shadow government and
it's firmly entrenched I think it would
be either naive or disingenuous to not
believe that yeah how do you how do you
then go on when you when you have these
thoughts all right I add I just think
that no one really and I'm saying this
unit wants to hear the complete truth
because a complete truth is there
probably are aliens their problems I
don't know what the answers but I
disagree that a president can make a
change I think we as individuals have to
understand the idea that some one person
is going to change every little terrible
thing is silliness yeah but he has made
a change as far as health care that's
affected my life in a better way in my
children's life so I mean I think that
people do make a change it's not as
grandiose as everybody wants it to be
because everybody wants everything right
now in three seconds and by the way the
president is only one-third of the
branches of government people seem to
think that he's a king or want him to be
a king but to your point about the Oba
about Obamacare so he got something that
was passed that worked for you but if
you remember when he was running he kept
saying we're gonna do this all open it's
all gonna be on c-span we're gonna show
you how we did it and of course they
didn't do that yeah so it's an
interesting blend of yeah something good
came out of the sausage machine at the
end but you know we wanted to sort of
see the how they do it and it also
depends on your on your perspective like
to me what was good about Obamacare
pales in comparison to the fact they
just stopped to the insurance industry
you know I mean if you if you really
wanted to make change you got to go
outside the system and I just believe
that the system is corrupting you choose
and spits out great statesmen and States
women even the most well-intended of
them but you know let's go back to
transparency what do you know about TPP
what do you know about that what do you
know about they saw me know if you have
any idea what's going on but with with
water in this country let alone globally
yeah they can't tell you the truth
because they would be rioting
the streets yeah so you're never gonna
get transparency well no we filled your
glasses up why don't you guys are you
guys are rebels we're on it anyway the
point is is there a shadow government do
you believe in aliens what was the
original point of this story that's not
the same thing those two things aren't
the same thing let us go in the comments
right now the way this is an extremely
titillating story Venice California's
neighborhood council wants women to be
treated to the same freedom as men when
it comes to going topless along the so
cal city shoreline council member melisa
diner presented a free the nipple bill
saying this is a serious equality issue
and i'm not going to shy away from it
diners bill passed the castle 12 22 now
members will be asking for Venice Beach
to be exempt from restrictions that
require women to cover their breasts in
public spaces the council said Venice
Beach was founded and designed around
the European culture of Venice Italy
topless sunbathing is commonplace
throughout Europe much of the rest of
the world in many places within the
United States all right so technically
right now we are in Venice are we not we
are on venice boulevard in venice
alright so oh wait you guys you saw
where we were going all you too i know
you like to take it as a feminist i say
let the titties go yeah free the breasts
free the nipples okay Europe they have
no problem with breasts they are doing
this on beaches people are not accosting
people people are not being sexually
attacked or assaulted why are we so
afraid of the breast well I actually
read that the council member that put
this a bill forward I guess it is a bill
said that she wants us to be more like
Europeans but like okay fine show your
boobies but do we have to want to do
everything like your beers like I don't
want to sit on a bday eat a new tell at
four in the morning at a rave and
Barcelona you know what it means I
actually doesn't sound terrible i know
that sounds very freeing but I think
that's totally fine let's show some
nipples but you know there was a video
that was going viral on Facebook of this
bodacious beautiful woman and chintan
gorgeous boobs in a crop top that was
barely below her nipples and she was
running like full-on down the beach in
slow motion and the only thing
thought is that just looks so painful
you know what I mean as a woman it's not
good for the back right yeah it just is
it is her cross to bear so to speak yeah
poor woman I tend to think you're okay
with us becoming a little more European
oh yeah well I mean our notions around
sex sexuality human anatomy just the
ridiculous they're you know they're
they're Puritan Christian driven things
that most people don't really care about
and just I do think it's tragic though
that there are a tiny little handful of
tiny little places in America where you
can swim naked in the ocean yeah I mean
that seems it seems very very wrong it
seems like to just take your clothes off
sit nasaan wander into the into the
water it's kind of a basic fundamental
human human animal reality man on earth
scenario yeah it's crazy yeah do you
think we're crazy that it's so dead
expect so restrict that it has to be
litigated and it's good ops analogous
it's pathetic it's pathetic do you think
it's weird that America we have such in
you know dislike constant dichotomy
between like what do I me wrong and then
also the man-woman thing but like to me
this is all I'm totally with you on that
like it's your body if we could gut not
be so hung up on this stuff then
everyone could do what they want and we
wouldn't I think we'd end up having less
sexual crime or whatever they fear is
gonna happen because of this I think we
would have less of if we get over the
hangers well we've I mean you know the
body is not sexual be nude is not
sexualizing yeah you know that how
that's been he conflated is a little
tragic too yeah until like the 1900s
even a man showing his nipples was
against the law well that that would be
that would be although as I get older
and flap your eye I I kind of want to
get one of those one-piece suits one of
those I wish those who come back one of
the little tiny why are you big mustache
yeah
10 months in Calgary in the hot spring
oh you did it was weird but still
comfortable no it did like just be vegan
kind of gross now you know what a sports
bras like Zach and actually was a rental
which like that's weird that changes
things good man to that now they just
weren't t-shirts when render the beers
are those t-shirts it's like come on
dude you're not tricking anyone we know
what's up we know anyways do you fear
the breast would it be okay if women
went topless in Venice or would the
wrath of God come down and destroy us
let us know your thoughts in the
comments right down below if you think
your high school experience was rough
check this out a boarding school in
China has installed metal bars on all
balconies after to third grade pupils
committed suicide in six months
punctuate number to Middle School home
to nearly 10,000 top performing students
is known for its highly stressful
military style management not only our
students forced to get up at 530am and
study for at least 10 hours a day but
all meals have a 15-minute time limit
and students are only given one holiday
every three years pictures of the
school's new balcony fence first
appeared last week on China's equivalent
of Twitter caption in order to prevent
pupils from jumping off the building
come join middle school has spent a
fortune another user commented this is
indeed a school but in order to stop
people from taking their lives it has
made itself look like a prison so I want
to do the story because I came across
one of those pictures on twitter with
the bars and it just blew my mind that
really what they're doing in these
schools is turning this into jail and
then what actually it looks like the
projects I grew up next to it wrongs
yeah so 10 hours this is some of those
numbers game what your hours of studying
a 15 minute break I mean this that's not
where that's pretty crazy suppose it's
not what the human experience of growing
up is supposed to be like right i think
when i read that and made me not feel so
bad about medicating my child is if you
medicate your child their quiet walk
around like zombies zombies can't jump
sabi you put a little red meat on the
other side is on beale jump no no no no
does this just seemed crazy like I know
I know what a lot of the commenters are
gonna say is that well look where China
is in the world in education they're
gonna say that's why they surpassed
America
so many things in there what's the rush
in the bars or their intense mode of
Education so let's start with the mode
of education first like is that just too
much empirically is that kind of
studying for third graders where they
could consider suicide is that just too
well and again we don't know ever I
don't know I let an expert in change did
you see they had a video and I also read
online that they have the children they
line up and they throw their hands in
the air we won't succeed and anytime I
see children throwing their hand in the
air and yelling we will succeed and
reminds me of Nazis yeah it is it is a
little Hitler oh happy I recite the
Pledge of Allegiance every morning makes
me think of Nazis to butt off gosh yes
you need Oh preventa on Twitter's
correctly there anything else Paul that
we can send the mystery I'll see who I
can piss off in the next segment yeah no
real alright so the bars I mean it just
doesn't that in and of itself for
getting the amount that they're working
but just to have kids in a learning
environment where they're tracked like
that doesn't that just seem crazy that's
crazy as far as safety wise if there's a
fire there is you know that is kind of
crazy they're attractive bars though you
have to admit the welding in it then no
the car x a lot but what do you think
about this in this I don't know look you
know we're all adults here and we can't
open a window in a hotel so I to judge
what do you think is worse like the
growing up in our education system where
so many kids are slip through the cracks
and then their whole lives are ruined
because they don't get the education
they deserve or going through something
that could break you but you're gonna
learn and then when I see stuff like
that I feel bad for China itself because
they're so regimented and so like strict
that there that the creative ones that
are there that are gonna actually bring
something creative and something out out
of the box to their society I think that
just kills that yeah so is that the part
they're missing so for 43 creative types
and comedy is that the part how do you
then I don't you to create they seem to
be doing they're doing great there are
no I mean what are you
what are you compare you're gonna say
it's worse than the education system
state education system here in America
by the way can I just say this to your
viewers yeah about the education see my
just so a fantastic documentary called
waiting for superman which is really
really terrific if you're interested in
how and why our education system is is
in such trouble this documentary gets
into the problems what how hard it is to
fix our education system so i just want
to pass that on yeah after watching that
movie what is the one thing you took
away from that movie about the education
system that's specifically wrong um it's
it's become a bureaucratic nightmare and
so to effect change is virtually
impossible because you're dealing with
people's livelihoods and you're dealing
with with union rules and you're dealing
with all sorts of structures that make
it impossible to do any fundamental
changes and until the institution of
this bureaucracy can change it's very
difficult to affect change from within
it but but i just wanted to pass on i'm
not speaking for it i just think it's a
fascinating duck no well i think that's
actually a good take away their so okay
we've got our system right here totally
warped at our education systems is one
of the worst in the western world we've
got china where it seems to be working
right their economy is going great and
yet they have bars on their windows so
if you're in a country that's somewhere
between those things you're saying what
you're saying that like it's not true
here I mean what bars on half the
schools in New York right but what
worthy but with the bars not to stop the
kids from killing themselves you is to
stop violence I guess the outsiders
coming in or I don't know I what's the
difference the system is seriously
[ __ ] what do you think let us know in
the comments right down below robot
bartenders are here to serve us drinks
and ultimately destroy us the maker
shaker a new bartending robot consists
of automated arms that mix cocktails and
places them on a conveyor belt to be
carried across the bar to the waiting
however the goal isn't to do away with
bartenders who are still needed to tend
the machines the co-founder of maker
shaker and MIT professor explains it
started at something to shock people in
a tangible way and to show them what the
third Industrial Revolution is all about
the first two installations of the maker
shaker can be found royal caribbean's
cruise ship Bionic bar alright so it's
not here to replace bartenders accept
all bartenders are gonna be doing are
repairing the machines so bartenders are
basically becoming repairman right so
look again we've talked about a little
bit of open the pod bay door Hal gasps
jamess so we already talked we talked a
little bit about how in 2001 before and
I love this future stuff this one struck
me is sad well I'm not even gonna go to
the robots are gonna kill us think this
one struck me as we're so disconnected
from humans that there is something to
do you ever have a bar at any time in
your life they used to go to and they
knew your name and you could sit down
and talk to the bartender because that's
gone right well listen if I want a robot
to make me a drink and not talk to me I
would just get married again all right
y'all data right by the way we got to
rim shots or whatever we do that if
they're the face that that was on a
Royal Caribbean cruise and I think if
you're if they're gonna put money into
putting a robot on a cruise ship it
should be one to be able to wipe up some
norovirus all over that that's where
they should put those robotics in yeah
how about habit just to push the giant
fat people away from the buffet for some
angry comments on that one what do you
think when you've missed the the
old-school cheers when you miss Sam
alone knowing your name when you came in
I've never experienced that most most
operations yes drink my makeup I do
drink but not not very much at all okay
but um um yeah I guess but I don't know
I don't know I unless that that's barely
a blip on the radar that is nothing that
means anything to me yeah I can't I want
to get behind this in some way but yeah
I just think it will see feel terrible
if you code
up to a bar and there's a robot
bartender and you still couldn't get his
attention get a job I will say this
though no tipping ah but you have to tip
the guy who's fixing it in the back that
poor schmuck I think we can make that
rule right now no till we're not oh
that's why I feel sorry for are the
bartender's that have to fix it like you
know not only are you relegated to be a
being a bartender you got to get a
degree in IT you know be a bartender
yeah you have to fix them what do you
think about the part about just
disconnecting us from humans because
that I do think I mean every story that
we do now is some other thing where it's
all about us looking in our phones and
all this stuff but I wish you know I
wish that disconnected from the humans
thing was true cuz I I'm not a big fan
of most humans yeah because of the
internet I interact with more people
every day now than I ever have in my
life yeah so I don't really get real is
it real interaction has your back and
forth on Twitter and no no it's not just
Twitter but it's really true action and
and interestingly enough yes because the
stimulus comes from a million different
directions conversations can get really
interesting in any number of formats but
i find myself you know here's the thing
you could be a doug stanhope fan you
know find yourself talking about Doug
Stanhope fan and Romania yeah or you
know you can be the arcade fire fan and
find yourself talking to somebody in
China or you can talk again directly
actually sometimes that yeah exactly
yeah so um I think in many ways it what
it's what it's doing is it's eliminating
geography from tribalism that you now
can create tribes of like-minded people
that is you know the tribe exists
globally yeah and I think that's a
fascinating interesting part of social
interaction and I don't think we
interact with people s I don't I think
we direct with people more yeah yeah I
by the bigger idea there that we do more
I mean look I met both of you guys
basically through twitter because i do
Kele carlin and which we all connected
through twitter I've connected with a
zillion comedians that I love yeah
there's actually some really meaningful
friends in my life that I'd met through
various yeah and yet at the same time if
you go to the supermarket I'd find that
half the time I'm trying not to do it in
which I'm staring at my phone so that
little communication that little human
moment that you might have with the
clerk we're saying that sort of is
disappearing why is that why do you
consider that equality interaction what
goes for conversation may have online
right maybe it isn't at all but you know
people like to be acknowledged you know
I try it now I try to be very present
with the clerks cuz i was always staring
am I thinking of yeah there's a look
there's a little bit of sort of you know
politeness manners involved in that yeah
that's about me your honors that I've
lost ya get that back ya know we're
we're all guilty that a little bit but I
do like how you go to these places now
and show signs up we will not take your
order if you're on a cell phone you know
kind of thing which yeah this is the
backlash to that so that's kind of
interesting it'll come out in the wash
anyway uh what do you think let us know
in the comments right now below no
monkey business here this story is
totally bananas a pair of chimpanzees
may soon get a new lease on life thanks
to a new york state judge recognizing
them as legal persons in the ruling by
the New York Supreme Court the two
chimps Hercules and Leo are legally
covered by habeas corpus a law that
governs against unfair detention this
means the two chimps currently being
held at Stony Brook University for
biomedical research may have to be set
free the decision came two years after
the nonhuman Rights Project launched the
case to help free the two chimps the
group plans to launch similar legal
cases for whales dolphins great apes and
elephants I think the story is
completely fascinating you guys know a
big animal lover I you know I'm not a
fan of animal testing generally speaking
I know sometimes there are cases where
we have to do with mice but certainly
not for cosmetics and things like that
we know that what something like
ninety-nine percent of our genetic
makeup is the same as these chimps and
all that kind of stuff so I'm kinda down
with this I your child about your
children and loved it I just love the
blatant irony of the fact that chimps
these to at least have more rights than
everybody at Gitmo right just let me
close that you know we're not giving
actual humans habeas corpus status book
will give it to chimps
I'm not sure how to judge that but I
love that that's just staring us all
enough yes well Paul for the record
these chimps aren't on any terror watch
lists which I don't I would not I don't
know they all they have those beers yeah
and they're gonna any pitcher banana
peel oh that's funny the throw banana
peel it can be quite dangerous that
could be dangerous yeah what do you
think about this is this a slippery
somebody's gonna make a slippery slope
argument right I look they're adorable I
totally get it but I think it is a
little bit slippery slope and then our
we're not gonna be allowed to say things
I dude with a [ __ ] like now we're not
gonna be able to say you know I get like
worse is all that I mean you know when
when they riot they ride right he really
rises me the police are dodging poo so
where do you guys think this goes as far
as animal rights in general so like
chimps I can see the sort of logic there
but then they listen to the whales and
you know do humans have some special
thing about us that we should be
separate from all these things well I
have mixed feelings about I mean when
you see those Ricky Gervais Instagram
photos of like the white chick next to
the dead giraffe it's like yeah I
totally get it that it makes more sense
yeah but I don't want it to interfere
with how I treat my dog I'm because it's
a doll your dog is just a dog right no I
mean I feel it's I feel it's a slip
yourself like is it gonna get to the
point where like if I have a dog and it
and let's just say for example he has a
little like a fat bubble that's on him
if I don't get it fixed is there gonna
is the vet gonna get me in trouble
because I'm not getting a fix because
I'm from Kansas and the dog is a f'in
dog they got a copy protection suppose
you protection services like where it is
kind of a slippery slope but I do
understand it and I applaud that that
happen it is crazy but here's my
question is that how did this come about
like are these chimps not somebody's
property as your dog is your property
right I don't want to get into the the
like our sign language but are they know
I mean how why isn't this falling under
property law wise is going into a habeas
corpus yeah just it just doesn't yeah
well I'm not a lawyer so I don't
I had no idea yeah I have no idea but to
your point about you know judging people
with their own animals there's a guy on
my street who walks a little a little
pug you know like a 15 pound bug this
thing has a goiter or something some
sort of growth that is literally like
half the size of a basketball like huge
huge and I always want to say that I've
seen this dog now four months and he can
barely walk in it's you know it's almost
dragging this thing I always want to
save it a guy like are you what's going
on here are you taking care of that or
whatever but I have no right obviously
you say that well who knows what he's
doing or will we be able to pay chimps
seventy percent on the dollar yes right
Network yeah I can do that yeah I did
the Republicans will be we can women get
77 what does that say about it what's
that about yeah all right so it's Chevy
7 i'm sorry i had the wrong number so
wait what you're saying is it should be
eighty cents for the chimps and 77 cents
i think if we make if we make chimps if
we put them in the same category as
human beings we identify them legally as
humans will have slavery again i know
somebody will come along and start
selling slave champs anyway let us know
what you think in the comments right
down below alright that is the big show
for this week I'm gonna let you guys
pimp yourselves out where feel the good
people find you on the computer machine
they can find me at twitter and
instagram and facebook just falesha
Michaels that's good branding I always
like when people have good branding you
a pretty solid branding if i'm not
mistaken tell the good people well I'm
my new project is I will be ambassador
to China that's what we learned here
yeah but the UN yeah and now I'm just
I'm around and I'm like an STD you can
find me here they are you picked it up
at Paul Provenza on the Twitter and on
that Reuben reporting all that good
stuff thanks for watching guys we will
do it again next week